- I just saw this video of you
you posted of your baby girl.
We're gonna show it.
(audience moans)
She's super cute.
(audience claps)
- [Alex] Oh, thank you.
She had so much fun.
She's a water baby.
- I love that.
I love the water.
I think it feels rejuvenating.
So any sign she's gonna be into soccer?
- Oh, well she better, you know,
no pressure, but we'll see.
I keep putting a soccer
ball in front of her
and she wants nothing to do with it.
So hopefully one day.
- Well, how is your prep for
the Tokyo Olympics going?
- Oh, it's good.
I mean, we are in like full
prep mode and, you know,
on the field every single day,
getting ready and obviously
you know, looking forward to it so much.
And for me, I kind of get a second chance
because it would have been really close
to after having my daughter last year.
So now pushing it to this year,
I'm really excited for
that second opportunity.
- [Kelly] Yeah, silver lining.